wollt ihr mich verarschen alter ich habe
ein solarpanel abgebaute kriegt ein
generator ohne wird jetzt mal ganz kurze
wollen die mich veräppeln
soweit ich schnapp jetzt meine ganzen
trizeps hier und fliegt jetzt mal ganz
kurz zu den bäumen dahinten spark meinte
man darf die benutzten oder hat er die
sich auf sein grundstück gepackt
milliarden weg die holtwicker weggeholt
mensch dass es muss irgendwie an ran
komme
rips und da ist die kern jetzt komplett
ausdrücklich darauf hin nicht nur ich
behinderte da warst du mich gefragt hey
da bin ich wieder ich brauche aber und
da ist wartet ein extra so brammer dran
sowie der die auf twitter wächst alter
ich mache das auch ich habe dich ja ich
brauche aber ich brauche definitiv aber
ich hab kein bock die jetzt ganz warte
nämlich nicht nur web links irgendwie
kann ich abbauen und dann kommen dass
sap links raus oder soll ich weiß gar
nicht so gut auf jeden fall die roboter
hinten wohl weg bekommt heraus 9 13
jahre das reicht eigentlich essen
12 ein paar koffer campbell 39 ist es
eigentlich erst mal reichen wir mal
wieder alles in die kiste eine ganze
nation habe fackeln eine fackel setzte
kommt dass ich neue hin ihr kommt nicht
schon so was brauche ich denn jetzt
alles für solar teil solar das glas
einfach nur noch 1 1
ich brauche auch keinen mehr eigentlich
generell tabu eine menge elektronik
circuit wie vielleicht davon habe ich
noch einen war nach vier davon habe ich
schon vier solar panel des 15
electronic circle brauche ich quasi nur
noch und das ist ok dass meine mutter
cool kopper cable rief ihren körper
cable
so da habe ich auf jeden fall schon mal
ein bisschen was so jetzt nochmal
solarpanel ohne so ja ich weiß ich kann
die rezepte immer noch nicht auswendig
und kraftwerke ich komme beziehungsweise
besseres kraftwerk durch lagen wir ganz
gut wieder die sachen roboters com
wir können wir einpacken ich musste auf
jeden fall meine tür hinrunde von dem
fliegen sondern kommt auch noch mit 1
auch relativ wertvoll
dennoch lassen da muss noch eine türe
nicht jetzt erstmal ganz so freunde low
voltage block kommt alter mann links das
tut nicht weh aber das tut gut wenn ich
so mache höher so dann brauche ich den
jetzt erstmal ab dafür brennt da ist ich
dachte nicht falsch machen jetzt ein
jetpack ist auch fast zur hälfte wieder
so ein bisschen
achso den lv transform blog klar ich hab
den generate abgebaut
wollt ihr mich verarschen alter
ich habe ein solarpanel abgebaute trägt
ein generator ohne wird jetzt mal ganz
kurz wollen die mich veräppeln
warte mal ganz kurz ach ich dachte ich
hätte ihn schon abgebaut aber habe ich
gar nicht alter wollen mich verarschen
die haben einfach so sondern du so ein
solarpanel jetzt mal weg genommen alter
da oben war ein solarpanel drauf ja kein
ding vize wiesner macht ja nichts oder
wird das immer so da bin ich jetzt
einfach kraftvolle vollidiot auch jetzt
muss mir noch so alles machen oder wie
ja kaum einer geht noch
geht noch geht noch weiter ich bin ich
zu blöd einfach da bräuchte hat mit der
ranch ab lopaka verify nicht aufhellen
man jetzt müssen wir noch mal so ein
ding machen
jetzt habe ich auch nur ein woran
hapert's am körper scheiße ist das
behindert
jetzt aber schon ein bisschen kinder
müssten jedoch zugestehen
januar habe ich electronics türke
brauche ich kommentieren
da habe ich schon zwei davon glas und
kohle ist das ärgerlich ist das
ärgerlich freunde das doch echt traurig
oder hey ich hab acht juhu so warte
jetzt mal ganz kurz nein nein place kopf
und körper cable
kommt euch beide watte flip flop
natürlich war damit seien kopf und
körper cable was soll ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz
da müsst ihr hin da muss kupfer hin und
damit das kupferkabel hin dann habe ich
einen lv transformator der kommt in der
mitte
ja ich habe einen lauf wolltet stegen
endlich ja es ist anja 10.000 mehr
10.000 ist das dell ernst ich krieg
10.000 verdammte scheiße mehr alter das
ist nur 10.000 energie man meinen
jetpack allein brauch schon voll viel
ist das scheiße alte macht richtig viel
ich arbeite hier die ganze dass diese
kacke gelaufen zum laufen krieg hier
wie viel macht das denkt sich dass wir
nicht irgendwo solarenergie was bringt
das denn wenn nicht ich schaue mal ganz
kurz was was man mit uran alles machen
kann
uranium blog übrigens alle leute
geschrieben apatit kann man sehen dass
daraus kann man sich ihn wieder machen
oder so wartet das abgespeichert höhe da
apatit zwei sind dann kriege ich
irgendwie so abartig pulver oder weil
sie nicht
hanni drop dafür muss sich imker werden
so das heißt das nächste an das sich
schließt das hier mal ganz kurz dann
kann ich das hier wieder ein bisschen
größer ziehen audacity das nächste was
mit 16 wert ist ein roter remains rater
damit das ganze ein bisschen schneller
geht
rotary mails rey rief einen habe ich
genug major habe ich auch
so dass halten
es ist ein maschinen blog den habe ich
auch carbon platte blau carbon le
carbone februar holt das heißt 6
die beiden nebeneinander frau dann habe
ich daraus nur drei rollen sind immer
weniger cool wenn einander und das dann
in ein kompressor experte geht auch auf
oder kompressor das ist ein kompressor
ok ich brauche erstmal kompressor hat es
einfach geschehen blog elektronik gibt
viele steine habe ich nicht steine hier
irgendwo habe ich nicht steine hat keine
stelle ich euch mal ganz kurz jetzt auch
sagt euch damit daraus wird doch dann
sammelt oder das hier ist ein ofen alex
oder kupfer drum
erst mal ganz kurz ich brauche ich nicht
mehr das ganze inventar hier packe ich
erst mal ganz kurz raus hier die diamant
schaufel ja cool so kompakt braucht auch
nicht schon dass ihr nicht seht also ich
schaue sehr selten gerade in den kamera
ganz einfach weil ich gerade relativ
fokussiert auf das spiel bin deswegen
habe ich gesagt diese folgen wo ich
einfach nur bauer wollte ich eigentlich
keine kamera ein baum vor allem meine
schultern und erwähne ich zitiere ganz
nach unten jetzt gehen wir offen halten
und so viele quatschen das ist
unglaublich ich weiß auch noch heraus
fordern wir schon anderthalb stunden
wieder aufnehmen
sieht immer so aus als hätte haben aber
das ist einfach nur so weiß nicht so
habe ich hier immer so
augenringe augenringen ist das nicht
jedenfalls tatsache
echt jetzt wenn ich zehn das reicht
schon längst anämisch davon den
maschinen blog habe ich natürlich einen
da hat euch einen da ist ein blog alex
circuit habe ich glaube ich noch ein
dann könnte noch alle hab ich noch ein
dann habe ich schon mal ein kompressor
falschen leute so dass der kompressor
den muss jetzt damit verbindet körper
cable so taktieren dahin nicht irgendwie
da oben geht man strom von weg
das kann ich jetzt nicht diese
funktioniert das nicht
warum nicht kommt da keinen strohmann
oder was ich hab ihn doch sogar richtig
daran oder her habe ich sogar ich nicht
verstehe ich gar nicht
wo ist mein kompressor hin
fick dich spiel fick dich alltag
wieso kann ich so was nicht mehr abbauen
ohne dass das in alle möglichen
einzelteile zerfällt das ist das denn
für ein scheiß alter das regt mich schon
wieder voll auf und der electric circus
ist jetzt einfach weg oder wie zwei
steine sind auch jetzt einfach weg
bewusst mit restlicher stein getan daher
leute aber jetzt können lernt man
scheint es auch einfach weg stellten
einfach weg ist es nicht wertvoller
machen bislang macht ja nix wieso
funktioniert das denn auch nicht muss
ich kann ich dir nicht da hinten dann
noch irgendwie dran setzen oder so ich
meine hier vorne müsste theoretisch auch
noch ein dings weg gehen auch man jetzt
brauche ich noch mal so ein verklagten
electronics circus ihr körper kann ich
mir so viel kompakter
doch nicht verarschen so dass das letzte
kupferkabel was jetzt habe ich einfach
zu wenig weil ich einfach zu wenig aber
habe ich jetzt noch den stein
rechtfertigt diese spiele ich kann es
gar nicht einfach umbringen
vor allem die ich möchte dass ich möchte
das drehen beziehungsweise abbauen und
ist der fällt einfach mal so dass jetzt
mein ding ich habe kein kabel mehr leute
wenn da wieso wenn das jetzt nicht
funktioniert dann ist wenigstens ein
kabel hingegangen
ich weiß es gar nicht